american superstar wesley saw you had a
nice day today came back and you're not
in second place how does it feel yeah
you're so kind i mean
i usually do
decently in blitz like plus one plus two
last three at the most so i mean
plus two is okay i guess i'm pretty
disappointed with my crucial game
against uh jordan because also i was
playing a risk-free position
and just king eight in the end in
blender but uh
um but speaking of crucial games i mean
you beat you beat magnus
yeah yeah yeah that's true i beat him
also in norway with black uh generally
oh in that game he played one a4 in the
blitz i mean it doesn't matter what you
play
you still beat him yeah i mean once
magnus gets going it's hard for him to
it's hard to stop him so that kind of
slowed him down a bit but
not very long i knew he was gonna play
very ambitiously against me
and
yeah somehow he said he just
made mistakes but uh
yeah overall i think pretty a pretty
solid day for me i didn't have much
problems with my black openings actually
you come up with some cool ideas
including the spanish with h6 97
destroying your pawn structure do you
feel comfortable revealing novelties
during blitz thank you yeah um
well
i
try to play what i know for blitz i
don't like playing i try to avoid
playing new openings new lines which
requires a lot of memorization try to
save them for classical
like most of the openings i play today
are openings i've already played with
countless times so i feel
very comfortable know one e45 all the
time and basically
just
it's important to play what you know the
best
for a fast time control especially yeah
want to have points away from magnus
carlsen what's it gonna take for you to
catch him tomorrow
uh well there are a lot of
players
trying to catch him and not only me but
also well you're the one in second place
though
am i clear second yes sir
yeah somehow the results uh outside is
not always updated but uh
i mean yeah it's very hard to catch
magnus he's the number one player
i was hoping that he wouldn't get going
i in the rapid it seems like he wasn't
really
playing his best like he lost the shaq
and he wasn't
he missed a lot of chances
against me and linear but
winning five in a row and blitz i guess
someone just has to start winning game
after game like ian also at some point
they almost started winning game after
game yeah it seems like he's bouncing
back in the tournament after a mediocre
rapid yeah i think it's very
monumental it it's uh it blitz is about
rhythm so once you win a game or two you
can easily win a lot of games like in
norway i won four or five games in a row
in blitz is that the plan tomorrow
yeah if you win one game and then you
win a second one then usually
numbers it flows right yeah then it
flows but uh
yeah i mean someone has to have to win
enough games if they want to catch uh
magnus probably someone has to catch on
on fire well let's hope that it's you
wesley so he is currently one point and
a half away from magnus carlsen i know
that he's going to be trying his best
for first place tomorrow guys here from
zagreb we have wesley so we'll have
jordan very soon no pressure no pressure